This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vetantam. Hi, how are you? Thank you! Sarah and David Risa recently bought a place outside of Washington DC. They sound excited because this is the first time they're hosting both their families. We are making today a vegetable frittata with tomato, basil and goat cheese. We've got home fries. Sarah and David wanted to start a new tradition. Cook brunch with ingredients from their home garden.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。嗨，你好吗？谢谢！萨拉和大卫·里萨最近在华盛顿特区郊外买了一处房产。听起来他们很兴奋，因为这是他们第一次同时接待双方的家人。我们今天要做的是一道番茄、罗勒和山羊奶酪蔬菜烘蛋。我们还准备了家常炸薯条。萨拉和大卫想开启一项新的传统。用他们自家花园里种的食材来做早午餐。
The home fries have rose married from our garden and the potato has basil from our garden. This is Sarah's way of going back to her family's roots. She remembers her mother doing the very same thing. I remember growing up my mom had a garden and she would always come back with like these tiny little tomatoes and be like, I provided for my family, look, family, I grew this and we're like, yeah, that's the smallest tomato ever. But there's something about being able to grow stuff and being able to give it to people that you love that's pretty exciting. So yeah.
炸薯条里有我们花园里的迷迭香，土豆里有我们花园里的罗勒。这是萨拉回归家族之根的方式。她记得她的母亲也做过完全一样的事情。我记得在我成长过程中，我妈妈有一个花园，她总是会带回一些像这样微型的小番茄，然后说：“我为我的家人付出了，看呐，家人，这是我种的。”而我们就会说：“天哪，这是有史以来最小的番茄。”但能够亲手种植东西，并把它送给你所爱的人，这种感觉真的很奇妙。所以，是的。
My grandmother would always say that this is Sarah's brother's act. The sharing food is important, but I'd say the most important part is being around the table. But food was the lure to get everyone up. Yeah, exactly. We kept us there. Yeah, exactly. Food brought us together, but it was the company and the conversation.
我祖母常说，这是萨拉哥哥的行为。分享食物很重要，但我认为最重要的事情是围坐在一起。不过食物是把大家吸引过来的诱惑。对，没错。它把我们留在了那里。对，没错。食物把我们凝聚在一起，但维系我们的却是陪伴和交谈。
Today on Hidden Brain, the profound role that food plays in our lives. Food is not just nutrition that goes in your mouth or even pleasant sensations that go with it. It connects to your whole life. We look at the culture and psychology that determine what we eat, what we spit out, and when we come back for more. Paul Rosen has been studying the psychology and culture of food for more than 40 years.
今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨食物在我们生活中扮演的深远角色。食物不仅仅是送进你嘴里的营养，甚至也不仅仅是与之相伴的美妙感官体验。它与你的整个人生息息相关。我们将探讨决定我们吃什么、吐什么以及什么时候想再来一份的文化与心理学。保罗·罗赞研究食物的心理学和文化已经超过40年了。
He works at the University of Pennsylvania. Early in his career, Paul found himself pondering a question that few of us might think to ask, why do so many people across the world enjoy the hot, stinging pain of chili peppers? This question took Paul to a small village in Mexico, where chili peppers were as common as salt and pepper in the United States. They don't think their food tastes good without it, and the little kids don't like it. So something happens somewhere between two and five years of age. At the meals where everybody adult is eating the hot pepper and the older children are, and they're enjoying it and a little kid is thinking it's terrible and after a while some magic occurs and the little kids like it. So I thought well we had there a number of possible accounts.
他在宾夕法尼亚大学工作。在他的职业生涯早期，保罗发现自己陷入了一个我们当中很少有人会去想的问题：为什么世界上会有那么多人喜欢辣椒那种火辣、刺痛的痛感？这个问题把保罗带到了墨西哥的一个小村庄，在那里，辣椒就像美国的盐和胡椒一样普遍。他们觉得没有辣椒的食物不好吃，而小孩子则不喜欢它。所以，在两岁到五岁之间的某个时候，有些事情发生了变化。在所有成年人和大龄儿童都在吃辣椒、享受辣椒的饭桌上，小孩子却觉得这太糟糕了，而过了一段时间，某种神奇的事情发生了，小孩子们也开始喜欢它了。所以我想，我们对此有几种可能的解释。
Some accounts involve something fundamentally biological. And presumably the biological explanation would be if you start eating it long enough, you're eventually just going to like it for biological reasons. Yes, that's right. The brain compensates for all sorts of things. We adapt to things. This is a case of more than adaptation, where you're turning something that's negative into something positive.
有些解释涉及某种根本上的生物学机制。据推测，生物学上的解释会是：如果你开始吃的时间足够长，出于生物学的原因，你最终自然就会喜欢上它。是的，没。错。大脑会对各种事情进行补偿。我们会适应各种事情。这不仅是适应的问题，你是在把某种消极的东西变成积极的东西。
I mean, to me, that's an amazing thing that we can start with something that's innately negative and make it really positive. So I said, let's take a look at the animals in the village because the dogs and the pigs eat Mexican food. They're eating tacos and hot sauce and beans and all of that's love. So I went around the village and I first asked people, do you have any dogs or pigs that like hot pepper? And they said, what are you crazy? I said, well, yeah, I mean they eat it.
我的意思是，对我来说，这是一件了不起的事：我们可以从某种天生消极的东西开始，把它变成非常积极的东西。所以我说，让我们来看看村子里的动物，因为这里的狗和猪也吃墨西哥食物。它们吃塔可、辣酱、豆子，所有这些都是爱。所以我走遍了全村，首先问人们：“你们有没有喜欢吃辣椒的狗或猪？”他们说：“你疯了吗？”我说：“好吧，我是说，它们确实吃啊。”
And they said, that's ridiculous. I I said, well, yeah, I mean, they eat it. And they said, that's ridiculous. I said, would you mind if I give the dogs a little piece of cracker with some hot sauce on it and without and see what they choose? So they said, go ahead. And so I did, but go around the village with pigs and dogs. I put up one cracker in front of them with hot pepper sauce and another without, and I'd see what they did.
他们说：“这太荒谬了。”我说：“好吧，我是说，它们确实吃啊。”他们说：“这太荒谬了。”我说：“你们介意我给狗一块抹了辣酱的饼干，看看它们会怎么选吗？”他们说：“去吧。”于是我就照做了，带着猪和狗在村子里转悠。我在它们面前放了一块抹了辣椒酱的饼干，另一块没有，然后看它们的反应。
And it turns out that none of them ate the hot pepper first. They all ate the one without pepper because they're hungry, but their first choice was the one without hot pepper. So that I couldn't find an animal in the village that did what everyone over five years old in humans did, which was to gobbelist up out and prefer it. So that suggested to me that it seems to be uniquely human. And so this is not just a question of people getting used to it and getting to like it,
结果证明，它们没有一只先吃带辣椒的。它们全都吃了没有辣椒的那块，因为它们饿了，但它们的第一选择是没有辣椒的那块。所以我找不到村里有哪只动物会像五岁以上的人类那样，狼吞虎咽地把辣椒吃下去并且更偏爱它。这向我表明，这似乎是人类独有的。所以这不仅仅是一个人们习惯它并开始喜欢它的问题，
because the dogs and pigs are eating the garbage, the garbage is laced with chili peppers. If that was the case, that would be true for the animals as well. So what was happening in the humans, in the human brain, if you will, that allowed five-year-old children to fall in love with chili peppers and kept their canine cousins from liking it. Well, that's indeed exactly the question. We don't know how this happens, but we do know that where it happens is at the meals
因为狗和猪也在吃垃圾，垃圾里混有辣椒。如果真是那样的话，动物也应该如此。那么，在人类身上，在人脑中到底发生了什么（如果你愿意这么说的话），才使得五岁的小孩爱上了辣椒，而它们的犬科表亲却对它提不起兴趣？嗯，这确实正是问题所在。我们不知道这是怎么发生的，但我们确实知道它发生的地方是在饭桌上，
where the kids are eating with their parents and their older siblings, and they keep eating it because the social pressure to eat it. Now, the animals keep eating it because the social pressure to eat it. Now, the animals keep eating it too because they're hungry, so it can't be just that they keep eating it. So, it's really, to me, a miracle. And what I realized is that it's a miracle that takes place in humans all over the world,
孩子们和父母以及较大的兄弟姐妹一起吃饭，他们不断地吃，是因为吃东西的社会压力。现在，动物们也在继续吃，因为吃东西的社会压力。现在，动物们饿了也会继续吃，所以不能仅仅归咎于它们一直在吃。所以，对我来说，这真是一个奇迹。我意识到，这是一个发生在世界各地人类身上的奇迹，
not just about hot pepper. It's also about liking coffee, which is bitter, and people don't like it originally, and they like it. And it goes outside the food domain. People like to go on roller coasters. Now, a roller coaster is a very negative experience the first time you have it, right? You think you're crashing to death, and your heart is pounding, and yet people pay to do this. Can you imagine a dog paying to go on a roller coaster? I mean, you know, it just won't happen. So we found that there's a whole range of things in which humans enjoy what is originally negative and they come to enjoy it as positive.
不仅仅是关于辣椒。它也关乎喜欢咖啡，咖啡是苦的，人们一开始并不喜欢它，但后来却喜欢上了它。而且它超出了食物的范畴。人们喜欢坐过山车。现在，第一次坐过山车是非常糟糕的体验，对吧？你觉得自己要坠毁身亡了，心跳加速，然而人们却花钱去体验这个。你能想象一只狗花钱去坐过山车吗？我是说，你知道的，这根本不可能发生。所以我们发现，人类有一系列的事情，他们会享受那些最初是负面的东西，并最终将它们视为积极的享受。
This includes the fatigue of running, it includes said movies, it includes being afraid in horror movies. This seems to be only humans. So our thought, and it's only a thought, is that what humans are enjoying is the very fact that their body thinks that something is bad, but they know it's okay. We call it benign masochism. The human have this special ability to appreciate the fact that they know that something that their body is saying is bad is actually good. And we have evidence for that. So for example, for chili pepper, the favorite degree of hotness is just below the level of unbearable pain.
这包括跑步的疲劳，包括悲伤的电影，包括在恐怖电影中感到害怕。这似乎是人类独有的。所以我们的想法——仅仅是一个想法——是人类真正享受的事实是：他们的身体认为某事是不好的，但他们知道其实没事。我们称之为良性虐恋。人类具有这种特殊的能力，能够欣赏这样一件事：他们知道身体发出的“情况不妙”的信号其实是安全的。我们有证据支持这一点。比如，对于辣椒来说，最受欢迎的辣度刚好在无法忍受的痛感之下。
They're pushing as far as they can to get their body to really screen, get this out of here, and yet know that it's okay. So it seems to be a very general feature of humans, which we tapped into by asking water a couple of billion people like hot pepper. So in some ways the theory is that you start out not liking it and then social pressure if you will, convinces you to try it and then you try it often enough that your body learns to adapt to it a little bit, but then eventually you start to like it for actually a slightly different reason.
他们尽可能地把身体逼到极限，让身体真正尖叫着喊“快把这东西拿开”，然而又知道其实一切都好。所以这似乎是人类的一个非常普遍的特征，我们通过询问几十亿人为什么喜欢辣椒来探究这一点。所以在某种程度上，这个理论是：你一开始并不喜欢它，然后社会压力（如果你愿意这么说的话）说服你去尝试它，接着你经常尝试，以至于你的身体学会了稍微适应它，但最终你开始喜欢它，其实是出于一个略有不同的原因。
You're no longer liking it just because of the pure pressure or the social interactions you're liking it because it gives you a sense that you're coming close to the edge of something thrilling. Is that the argument? Yes, there's something thrilling that is not threatening. Right. So for example, if something is threatening, you don't get to like it. Like people don't get to like serious pain. Right. It has to have something of the sense of it's not really threatening. And it even becomes funny. So in the case of disgust, people don't like disgusting things, right?
你不再仅仅因为同辈压力或社会交往而喜欢它，你喜欢它是因为它给你带来了一种感觉：你正接近某种惊险刺激的边缘。是这个论点吗？是的，有一种令人兴奋且不具威胁性的刺激。没错。例如，如果某事具有威胁性，你就不会喜欢它。就像人们不会喜欢严重的疼痛一样。没错。它必须带有一种“并非真的具有威胁性”的感觉。它甚至变得很有趣。所以在厌恶感方面，人们不喜欢令人厌恶的东西，对吧？
But they make exceptions. They eat smelly cheese. And they come to like that smell in the context of the cheese. Even though their body is saying, get this out of your mouth, it stinks. You once performed an experiment on yourself. You were with your wife, I believe, at a Korean restaurant in New York City, and you didn't interview with NPR back in 2015, where you told the reporter that it was one of the hottest things you'd ever eaten.
但他们会有例外。他们吃气味难闻的奶酪。并且在奶酪的语境下，他们开始喜欢那种气味。尽管他们的身体在说：“把它从你嘴里弄出去，这太臭了。”你曾经在自己身上做过一个实验。我记得你和你的妻子在纽约市的一家韩国餐馆，你在2015年接受NPR采访时，曾对记者说那是你吃过的最辣的东西之一。
Tell me that story. Well, my wife at the time was a cookbook writer, and she was very interested in cuisine. We went to a Korean restaurant in New York, and the people around us, they were ordering some dish that we didn't recognize. So we said to the waiter, we would like that. And he says, you don't want that. I said, no, no, we said, we really like to try new foods.
跟我讲讲那个故事吧。嗯，我当时的妻子是一位食谱作家，她对烹饪非常感兴趣。我们在纽约去了一家韩国餐馆，周围的人在点一些我们不认识的菜。所以我们对服务员说，我们想要那个。他说：“你们不会想吃那个的。”我说：“不，不，我们说，我们真的很想尝试新的食物。”
He says, you don't want to try that food. So this went on, and we won, of course, and he brought this dish and it was unbearably hot. And we ate it because we were shamed into eating it by our own insistence that it was good. I have another story of a different sort. It also happened in New York. I had a colleague who had a dog and the dog liked to eat dog poop. So they were going to Washington Square Park and with the dog and the dog, we just hunt out a dog poop and eat it and it was just awful. You know, they hated it and the dog smelled it.
他说：“你们不会想尝试那道菜的。”这种对话持续了一会儿，当然是我们赢了，他端上了这道菜，辣得令人难以忍受。我们把它吃光了，因为我们自己的坚持——说它是好东西——让我们觉得不吃不好意思，只好硬着头皮吃下去。我还有另一个不同类型的故事。它也发生在纽约。我有一个同事，他养了一只狗，这只狗喜欢吃狗屎。所以他们带着狗去华盛顿广场公园，然后那只狗突然找到一堆狗屎就吃了起来，真是糟透了。你知道的，他们讨厌这样，而且狗身上也有了气味。
So they went to a vet and the vet said, why don't you put hot pepper on the dog poop because dogs don't like hot pepper. So they go into Washington Square, wanting to get this image. Barbara's holding the dog on a leash and her husband goes with a shaker of hot pepper, finds a dog turn and seasons it in front of everybody with all this hot pepper. Okay. And I mean, the idea of someone seasoning a dog turn
于是他们去找兽医，兽医说：“你们为什么不在狗屎上撒点辣椒呢？因为狗不喜欢辣椒。”于是他们走进华盛顿广场，想要解决这个问题。芭芭拉用牵引绳牵着狗，她丈夫拿着一 shaker 辣椒粉，找到一坨狗屎，当着所有人的面在上面撒满了辣椒粉。好吧。我的意思是，有人给狗屎调味的这个想法，
is really pretty good. And then they let the dog go and the dog ate it. And did the dog stop eating dog poop? No, no, because the dog liked dog poop more than it does like the hotness. You know, people will put up with pain to do something they really like, right? Just as Paul has shown that the sense of taste is shaped by the brain, he's also done work that shows the same thing for appetite. In one study, he set a meal down before patients who had amnesia. Yes, the general view in most of the people who work on hunger
真的是相当不错。然后他们放开狗，狗把那坨屎吃了。那狗后来戒掉吃狗屎的习惯了吗？没有，没有，因为比起辣味，狗更喜欢狗屎。你知道的，人们为了做他们真正喜欢的事情会忍受痛苦，对吧？正如保罗所展示的那样，味觉是由大脑塑造的，他的另一项研究也表明，食欲也是如此。在一项研究中，他将一顿饭摆在了患有失忆症的病人面前。是的，大多数研究饥饿的人的普遍观点是，
is that hunger comes when your body reserves or low, or maybe your glucose is low, various hormones come out, and you feel this sensation of hunger and you eat until it disappears. Now there's some truth in that, of course, but there are many other higher order things. So for example, the cultural definition of what's a meal is very important.
饥饿的产生是因为你体内的能量储备不足，或者可能是你的葡萄糖水平低，各种激素分泌出来，然后你就会感到饥饿，并一直吃到这种感觉消失为止。这当然有一定道理，但还有许多其他更高层次的因素。例如，对“什么是正餐”的文化定义就非常重要。
After you finish the meal and have dessert, you stop eating. So to try to show this, we dealt with the two amnesic patients who were totally amnesic. They didn't remember anything that happened more than 30 seconds ago, but they were quite intact otherwise. So we fed them lunch in a situation where they were in a room without a clock. And we said lunchtime, and it was lunchtime, and we brought them a favorite lunch of this.
当你吃完饭并吃了甜点后，你就会停止进食。为了证明这一点，我们对两名完全失忆的失忆症患者进行了研究。他们不记得30秒前发生的任何事情，但在其他方面他们完全正常。因此，我们在一个没有时钟的房间里给他们提供午餐。我们说是吃午餐的时间了，当时确实是午餐时间，我们给他们端上了他们最喜欢的一份午餐。
We'd asked them what their lunch was, and they, they of course ate it. Then we took the plate away. There were no more signs that they'd eaten. And ten minutes later we brought another lunch and said lunchtime and they all ate it three times each. The second lunch completely. Then we took that away, waited ten minutes and brought a third lunch. Each of these were full-sized lunches. And most of the time they ate the third lunch, twice I think one of them said, I'm getting a little stuffed, meaning their stomach was really getting full. But the point was that when you serve the meal, it looks palatable, you tend to eat it.
我们问过他们午餐吃什么，他们当然吃完了。然后我们把盘子收走。没有任何迹象表明他们已经吃过了。十分钟后，我们又端来一份午餐，说该吃午餐了，他们三个人每人把这份午餐吃了三次。第二顿午餐被完全吃光了。然后我们把盘子收走，等了十分钟，又端来第三顿午餐。这些都是全尺寸的午餐。大多数时候，他们把第三顿午餐也吃完了，我想有两次其中一个人说：“我有点饱了，”意思是他们的胃真的装满了。但关键是，当你端上一顿饭时，它看起来很可口，你就会倾向于吃它。
I was on a plane once, flying to Chicago, and at three in the afternoon, they served the full lunch. Now, everyone had eaten lunch already. But six out of the nine people who I could see ate that lunch because it was lunch and it was food and it looked good. Probably wasn't good if it was airplane food, but they ate it. So a lot of what we do is we eat when there's good food around
我曾经坐飞机去芝加哥，下午三点的时候，他们提供了一顿丰盛的午餐。当时，每个人都已经吃过午餐了。但在我能看到的九个人中，有六个人吃了那顿午餐，因为那是午餐，是食物，而且看起来很好吃。如果那是飞机餐的话，可能并不好吃，但他们还是吃了。所以我们所做的大量事情是：当周围有美味的食物时，
and when the situation is appropriate. Now, if we had left their first lunch and they saw the plate in front of them with a, you know, there was pieces of chicken bone, they might have realized that I've just eaten. And when we give people, normal people, a second meal in the same way I just described, they don't say I'm not hungry, they say, I just ate.
且情境合适时，我们就会吃。现在，如果我们把他们的第一顿午餐留在那里，他们看到盘子摆在面前，里面有（你知道的）鸡骨头残渣，他们可能就会意识到我已经吃过了。而当我们给普通人提供第二顿餐食，就像我刚才描述的那样，他们不会说“我不饿”，而是会说“我刚吃过”。
So it's fascinating because I think what you're saying really is that memory plays a huge role in whether we think we're hungry. Yes, being hungry is only one reason that we eat. So if you go for a full dinner, halfway through that dinner you're not hungry anymore. Right. But you're still eating the rest of the meal. That's right.
所以这很迷人，因为我认为你真正想表达的是，记忆在决定我们是否觉得自己饿了方面扮演了巨大的角色。是的，感到饥饿只是我们进食的其中一个原因。因此，如果你去吃一顿丰盛的晚餐，在晚餐吃到一半时，你就不再觉得饿了。对。但你还是会把剩下的饭菜吃完。没错。
So hunger can't institute meals. The lack of it will probably discourage you from eating more, but there are other things that influence you too. When we come back, the role that culture plays in our experience of food, we also look at how you can serve more memorable meals. Stay with us. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
所以饥饿无法开启进食。缺少饥饿感可能会阻止你吃更多，但还有其他因素在影响着你。广告回来后，我们将探讨文化在我们对食物的体验中所扮演的角色，我们还将探讨如何提供更令人难忘的餐食。请继续收听。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
I'm talking with psychologist Paul Rosen, who has spent many decades examining the interplay between food, identity, and culture. Food is not just nutrition that goes in your mouth, or even pleasant sensations that go with it. It connects to your whole life and it's really a very important part of performing your culture and experiencing your culture. When Paul asked people about their favorite meals, they suddenly mentioned eating at great restaurants, but they also talk about memories of meals that they shared with family and friends.
我正在与心理学家保罗·罗赞交谈，他花费了数十年时间研究食物、身份认同和文化之间的相互作用。食物不仅仅是送进你嘴里的营养，甚至也不是与之相伴的美妙感官体验。它与你的整个人生息息相关，并且确实是践行你的文化和体验你的文化的一个非常重要的部分。当保罗询问人们他们最喜欢的餐食时，他们突然提到了在高档餐厅用餐的经历，但他们也会谈论与家人和朋友共享餐食的记忆。
Here's a very common answer that's very short for a home meal. Every Christmas Eve, my Italian grandfather and Greek grandmother would cook a meal, consisting of creamy carbonara with bacon pieces throughout, homemade spinach pie and sausage. It was always amazing. Now, that's a lovely one, right? And it's not fancy, but you can see the emotion and the pleasure of it. And it's connected, of course, to the pleasure of family, not just to the pleasure of food. Yes, it's very social.
以下是一个关于家常便餐非常常见且简短的回答。每年平安夜，我那意大利爷爷和希腊奶奶都会做一顿饭，包括奶油培根意面（里面布满了培根碎）、自制菠菜派和香肠。总是棒极了。看，这是一个很美好的回答，对吧？它并不花哨，但你能从中看到情感和快乐。当然，这与家庭的快乐息息相关，而不仅仅是食物带来的快乐。是的，这非常具有社交属性。
Pleasure is only one factor when it comes to what we eat and how much we eat. Contrast and context can be important. Consider the difference between a tapestile meal and a meal that's built around one large entree. In both cases, you can fill up your stomach. But it turns out, these have very different effects on your brain. As social scientists have found, most of us find it difficult to tell the difference between the tenth bite and the eleventh bite of the very same food. There's a whole line of modern decision research, most associated with Daniel Kahneman, who got a Nobel Prize for it, and Amos Torsky showing that people are not so rational as you
当谈到我们吃什么以及吃多少时，快乐只是其中一个因素。对比和语境也很重要。考虑一下小吃拼盘式的餐食与围绕一道大型主菜构建的餐食之间的区别。在这两种情况下，你都可以填饱肚子。但事实证明，它们对你大脑的影响截然不同。正如社会科学家所发现的那样，我们大多数人很难分辨出同一种食物的第十口和第十一口有什么区别。现代决策研究有一个完整的脉络，主要与丹尼尔·卡尼曼（因该研究获得诺贝尔奖）和阿莫斯·特沃斯基相关，他们表明人们并不像你
might expect them to be. And one of the features of it is called duration neglect, which is people don't remember how long an experience is. They just remember the experience. So if you had a pain for 12 hours or a pain for one hour, two weeks later, what you remember is the experience of the pain, not how long it was. So this applied to food means that if you have the same food, a lot of the same food, it won't produce a very different memory from having a little of that same food because it's the memory of eating the food. So this raises a very important question that Coniman originally brought up, which is the distinction between your experience and your memory for the experience.
所期望的那样理性。其中一个特征被称为“持续时间忽视”，也就是说人们并不记得一次体验持续了多长时间。他们只记得这次体验本身。所以如果你经历了12小时的疼痛或1小时的疼痛，两周后，你记住的是疼痛的体验，而不是它持续了多久。因此，这应用到食物上意味着：如果你吃相同的食物，吃很多同一种食物，它不会产生与只吃少量这种食物截然不同的记忆，因为关键在于吃这种食物的记忆。这就提出了一个卡尼曼最初提出的非常重要的问题，即你的体验与你对体验的记忆之间的区别。
Coniman and others have shown, we've done some work on this too, that the ending of an experience is particularly important. others have shown, we've done some work on this too, that the ending of an experience is particularly important. So when you remember something you're more likely to remember the end of it. And also by the way, to some extent more likely to remember the beginning of it. And that would mean if you want to produce the best memory for food, you should put the best foods at the beginning and the end, whereas most people think the entree is the best, which is in the middle and the end, whereas most people think the entree is the best, which is in the middle, and is the least remembered.
卡尼曼和其他人已经证明，我们在这一方面也做了一些研究：一次体验的结尾尤为重要。其他人已经证明，我们在这一方面也做了一些研究：一次体验的结尾尤为重要。所以当你回忆某事时，你更有可能记住它的结尾。顺便说一句，在某种程度上，你也更有可能记住它的开端。这意味着，如果你想为食物创造最好的记忆，你应该把最好的食物放在开头和结尾，而大多数人认为主菜是最好的，主菜在中间，也是最不容易被记住的部分。
We had Danny Kahneman on Hidden Brain recently, and of course he talked about the peak and rule, and also about the difference between the experiencing self and the remembering self. Yes. And one of the implications of this, as you point out, this difference between experiencing a meal and remembering a meal, is it points to the difference between people who go to restaurants and order their favorite dish every time and people who go to a restaurant and order a new dish every time. How do these two strategies essentially catering to two different psychological impulses? Well, that's an issue that we have looked at and it's pretty clear. If you're going to order your favorite food and you know you're going to order that before you go to the restaurant,
我们最近邀请了丹尼尔·卡尼曼做客《隐藏的大脑》，当然他谈到了“峰终定律”，以及体验自我与记忆自我的区别。是的。正如你所指出的，体验一顿饭与记忆一顿饭之间的这种区别，其含义之一就指向了那些每次去餐厅都点最爱菜肴的人，与每次去餐厅都点新菜肴的人之间的差异。这两种策略本质上迎合了两种不同的心理冲动吗？嗯，这是我们研究过的一个问题，而且答案很清楚。如果你打算点你最喜欢的食物，并且在去餐厅之前就知道你会点那个，
there are actually three aspects. There's your anticipation, this comes from Conor. The anticipation, the experience, and the memory. Your anticipation of a meal is going to be higher if you order your favorite food, because you know you're going to have something great, right? Whereas if you can order something new, it's not even clear what you can imagine,
实际上有三个方面。有你的预期——这来自卡尼曼。预期、体验和记忆。如果你点的是自己最喜欢的食物，你对一顿饭的预期会更高，因为你知道你将享用一顿美餐，对吧？而如果你点的是一样新的东西，你甚至不清楚你能想象出什么来，
because you don't know what it is. At the meal itself, you're probably gonna enjoy your favorite dish more than I knew this, because it's one of their best dishes. You love it. There's a little risk in ordering something, though. But if you order your favorite dish, you're not gonna create a new memory.
因为你不知道它是什么。在用餐本身时，你可能会比尝试新东西更享受你最喜欢的菜，因为那是他们最好的菜之一。你爱极了它。不过，点一样新的东西会有一些风险。但如果你点的是你最喜欢的菜，你不会创造新的记忆。
Whereas if you order a new food, you're gonna create a new memory. We are looking at this, but we don't know yet, for sure. If you're a person who generally values memories then you're going to try to create more memories by creating new experiences. Whereas if you value anticipation and experience more you will keep doing the same wonderful thing. So how you value anticipation, memory and experience affects how you're going to choose what activities
而如果你点了一道新食物，你将会创造一份新的记忆。我们正在研究这一点，但我们还不能百分之百确定。如果你是一个通常看重记忆的人，那么你会试图通过创造新的体验来创造更多的记忆。而如果你更看重预期和体验，你就会继续做那件同样美妙的事情。所以你如何看待预期、记忆和体验，会影响你如何选择要进行的活动。
you do. Let's just take an example. Massage. Okay, I like massage. I go once a month, I get a massage. It's pretty much the same. I can't tell you last month's massage was exactly this. So I'm going for the anticipation and the experience, which is very positive.
我们举个例子。按摩。好吧，我喜欢按摩。我一个月去一次，做一次按摩。基本上都差不多。我没法告诉你上个月的按摩具体是怎样的。所以我去是为了预期和体验，这是非常积极的。
I don't really create much memory from this. And I do it, and I like it, but it's very different from the way I eat, where I'm always trying to say, I want to enrich my mental menu listing, my life experience of food. But people differ on this. We've been interested in trying to see
我并没有从中创造出多少记忆。我去了，我也很喜欢，但这与我的饮食方式截然不同。在饮食上，我总是试图说：我想丰富我的精神菜单列表，丰富我的人生食物体验。但人们在这方面有所不同。我们一直很有兴趣去观察
if people are consistently different. We don't know yet. Think of a seven-day Caribbean vacation at a resort. Almost nothing happens, right? You're feeling good. It's sun is good. You go in the water. It's nice.
人们的这种差异是否具有一致性。我们目前还不知道。想想在加勒比海度假村的七天假期。几乎什么都没发生，对吧？你感觉很好。阳光很好。你下水游泳。感觉很棒。
But there's no. If people say, tell me about your vacation, it's going to be a very short thing, right? So there's two kinds of vacations. Those that are really high on experience, and vacations that will give you a lot of experience, but there will also be some hardship. You'll get tired, something may not work, something might be closed when you thought it was open. All kinds of things can happen. So it won't be a totally positive experience, but it will be a
但没有……如果人们问：“跟我讲讲你的假期吧，”这将是一个非常简短的回答，对吧？所以假期有两种。一种是体验感极高的假期，这些假期会给你带来很多体验，但其中也会伴随着一些艰难困苦。你会感到疲惫，某些事情可能不如预期，你以为开门的地方可能关门了。各种各样的事情都可能发生。所以这不会是一次完全积极的体验，但它会留下一堆美好的回忆。你深入思考过美国人对食物的态度与法国人对食物的态度之间的差异，你说法国人更关注嘴里发生的事情，而美国人通常更关注血液里发生的事情。我想放一小段电影片段来阐述这个观点。哇！要死啦，丫头！我要抓住你们。
bunch of good memories. You've thought a lot about the differences between the American attitude toward food and the French attitude toward food, and you say that the French are more focused on what happens in the mouth, and Americans are often more focused by what happens in the bloodstream. I want to play you a short movie clip that illustrates this idea. Wow! If I isn't dying or girl! I'm going to get you guys.
这里有什么东西是没糖、没碳水且零脂肪的吗？水。水。这就是问题所在？那段视频出自电影《灰姑娘的故事》，保罗，我想请你稍微谈谈这个，美国人对食物的态度与法国人对食物的态度。我去法国的次数挺多的，他们似乎比我们更能享受食物。
What can I get here that has no sugar, no carbs and is fat free? Water. Water. Was that the problem? So that was from the movie A Cinder Ella Story Paul, and I'm wondering if you can just talk a little bit about this, the American attitude toward food versus the French attitude toward food. I go to France a fair amount, and they seem to be enjoying their food more than we were.
有趣的是，他们的健康状况比我们略好一点。我的意思是，差距不是很大，但他们稍微长寿一些，心脏病发病率也更低。然而，他们饮食中的动物脂肪含量却比我们高。如果我们为食物担忧，
And interestingly enough, they're marginally healthier than we are. I mean, it's not a big difference, but they live a little longer and they have less heart disease. And yet they eat a diet that's higher in animal fat than we do. It's OK if we're worrying about food
而这样做的结果是我们能活得更久，那倒也罢了。但我们似乎既在为食物担忧，又没有活得更久。所以这似乎是一笔很不划算的买卖。因此我们开始了一项研究，关于法国人和美国人在饮食方式上有何不同。它基本上包括两个部分。一部分是他们如何看待食物，另一部分是他们的食物世界是如何构建的。法国人将食物视为一种口腔体验。他们认为吃东西是一件能带给他们
and the consequence of that is that we're going to live longer. But we seem to be worrying about food and not living longer. So that seems like a bad exchange. So we started a study of how French and Americans differ in the way they eat. And it's basically got two parts to it. One is how they think about food and the other is how their food world is set up. The French think about food as an oral experience. They think about eating as something that is giving them
快乐的事情。他们往往不会去想什么东西进入了他们的血液，动物脂肪里有多少糖。所以他们从食物中获得了更多的快乐，因为他们不为此担忧。例如，如果我们问法国人，当你想到浓奶油时，你会想到打发好的还是不健康的？他们通常会说打发好的，
pleasure. They don't tend to think about what's going into their bloodstream, how much sugar is in their animal fat. So they're getting more pleasure out of food, because they're not worrying about it. So for example, if we ask French, when you think of heavy cream, do you think of whipped or unhealthy? They will say usually whipped
而美国人则会说不健康。现在，东西是一样的，但他们把这看作一种体验，而我们更多地把它看作一件关乎健康的事。从某种程度上讲，这其实可能是一件好事，对吧？因为据推测，当你从食物中获得更多快乐时，你是专注于食物本身的，而不一定只是专注于把东西塞进嘴里或者专注于营养。例如，法国人似乎比美国人更注重分量控制，只不过我不知道他们是否把这当作一种“控制”。他们把这看作是对食物的享受。一旦我享受完了这一口，我就满足了。嗯，首先他们吃得更慢。所以他们有更多的口腔体验，
and Americans will say unhealthy. Now it's the same thing, but they're thinking about it as an experience and we're thinking about it more as a health event. And in some ways that actually might be a good thing, right? Because presumably when you take more pleasure in food, you're focused on it, you're not necessarily just focused on getting stuff in your mouth or focusing on nutrition. The French, for example, seem to pay more attention to portion control than Americans, except that I don't know if they're thinking about this as control. They're thinking about this as in the enjoyment of food. And once I'm done enjoying this bite, I'm done with it. Well, they eat more slowly, first of all. So they have more mouth experience
因为他们吞咽得没那么快。他们细细品味食物。所以我的意思是，如果你有一块巧克力，你可以几分钟内把它狼吞虎咽地吃完，或者你也可以把它变成一个持续10到15分钟的体验。他们更倾向于后者。我们实际上在巴黎的麦当劳测量过，人们坐着
because they don't swallow as quickly. They savor the food. So I mean, if you have a chocolate bar, you can bolt it down in a couple of minutes so you can make a 10 or 15 minute experience out of it. And they're more inclined to the latter. We actually were able to measure how, in McDonald's in Paris, how long people sat
吃东西的时间与美国麦当劳相比是怎样的。好吧，我们确保麦当劳里坐的是法国人，他们说的是法式法语。坐在麦当劳里的法国人坐的时间比坐在麦当劳里的美国人要长。所以他们比坐在麦当劳里的美国人坐的时间更长。所以他们吃得更慢，聊得更多，你知道的，他们不只是狼吞虎咽地吃东西。
and ate compared to the McDonald's in the United States. Okay, and we made sure they were French people in the McDonald's, they were talking French. The French people sitting in McDonald's sit there for longer than the American people sitting in McDonald's. So they're than the American people said in McDonald's. So they're eating more slowly, they're talking more, you know, they're not just bolting down food.
食物不是燃料。美国人经常（并非总是）把食物当成燃料。而法国人则认为它不是一种燃料补给，而是一场活动和一次体验。现在在饮食世界里，法国人和美国人的巨大差异在于食物的分量。法国传统上供应较小的分量。如果你看一本法国食谱，按人头计算，四人份的肉类分量比美国食谱要少。在法国的麦当劳，分量也更小。
Food is not fuel. Americans often, not always, treat food as fuel. Whereas the French think about it not as a fueling, but as an event and experience. Now in the food world, the big difference between the French and Americans is portion size. French traditionally serve smaller portions. If you look at a French cookbook, the amount of meat for four people per person is less than an American cookbook. In McDonald's, in France, the portions are smaller.
现在，如果你还记得我们之前讨论过的“你吃的是你面前的东西，如果它很美味的话”（那些失忆症患者就是这样），法国人摆在你面前的食物更少。所以他们吃得更少，却享受得更多。在我看来，这是一个很好的公式。现在他们还有其他的特点。法国人的正餐是一场更为精致的活动。人们不会中途离席，尤其是在家里。他们不会在吃到一半时突然离开餐桌。
Now if you remember our discussion of the fact that you eat what's in front of you, if it's pleasant, the amnesic patients, the French put less food in front of you. And so they're eating less and enjoying it more. And that seems to me to be a good formula. Now they have other features of it. The French meal is a much more elaborate event. People don't get up, especially at home. They don't get up in the middle of the meal and just leave the table.
每个人都吃同样的东西。所以这是一场社交活动。因此，我认为面对现代世界——周围有如此多的美味食物，以至于我们很容易让自己吃撑、把天下美食吃个遍——法国人很好地应对了食物的诱惑。他们成功地保持了一种
Everybody eats the same thing. So it's a social event. So I would say the French deal with food well in the face of the modern world, where there's so much good food around that we can easily stuff ourselves and eat everything under the sun. They have managed to have a tradition
适度且非常愉悦的传统。保罗·罗赞研究食物的心理学和文化已经超过40年了。他目前在宾夕法尼亚大学任教。保罗，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。不胜荣幸。快乐并不是我们坐下来吃饭时体验到的唯一感觉。食物还能唤起其他情绪，比如厌恶。休息之后，我们将更深入地探讨这种情绪。
which keeps it moderate and very pleasant. Paul Rosen has been studying the psychology and culture of food for over 40 years. He's currently at the University of Pennsylvania. Paul, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure. Pleasure is not the only feeling we experience when we sit down for a meal. Food can also evoke other emotions, like disgust. After the break, we are going to delve more deeply into this emotion.
为什么有些东西（如气味难闻的奶酪）让我们愉悦，而其他气味难闻的东西（如运动鞋）却让我们感到恶心？我们将这个问题抛给研究人员雷切尔·赫茨（Rachel Herz），并了解她为什么将“厌恶”称为必须学会的本能。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们产生厌恶情绪有一个简单的解释。
Why do some things, like smelly cheese, delight us, while other smelly things, like sneakers, disgust us? We pose that question to research a Rachel Hurts and find out why she calls disgust. The instinct that has to be learned. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There's a simple explanation for why we have the emotion of disgust.
它是对抗可能污染我们的东西的防御机制。然而，我们对于厌恶是如何运作的，往往有着充满缺陷的直觉，从什么是干净的、什么是肮脏的开始。心理学家雷切尔·赫茨在她的书《真恶心》（That's Disgusting）中，谈到了马桶座圈的清洁度与自动取款机（ATM）按钮相比如何。心理学家雷切尔·赫茨谈到了马桶座圈的清洁度与自动取款机（ATM）按钮相比如何。那些我们实际上经常触摸、却完全不知道或根本不认为它们
It's a defense mechanism against things that could contaminate us. Where we often have flawed intuitions about how disgust works, starting with what's clean and what's dirty. In her book, That's Disgusting, psychologist Rachel Hurst talks about how the cleanliness of toilet seats compares to buttons on an ATM. The psychologist Rachel Hurts talks about how the cleanliness of toilet seats compares to buttons on an ATM. Things that we actually touched a lot and have no idea or don't really think about how
有多么恶心的东西，比如ATM按钮，实际上还有手机，简直就是病原体和细菌的培养皿，而且我们大多数人并不经常清洁手机。然而，由于我们大脑中建立的特定联想（非常具体地将马桶与人体排泄物联系起来），我们脑子里有这样一种观念：马桶真的、真的非常肮脏。然而，对于键盘、手机以及人们一直在触摸、可能非常脏且具有传染性的其他东西，我们却连想都不想。我想谈谈令人厌恶的事物所具有的一种特定特质，雷切尔，那就是它们往往几乎会“传染”它们周围的东西。正如在厌恶情绪方面做过大量研究的心理学家保罗·罗赞所说，一只蟑螂会毁掉一碗樱桃的吸引力，但一颗樱桃却不会让一碗蟑螂变得有吸引力。为什么令人厌恶的东西会传染它们周围的东西呢？好吧，首先我想把
disgusting they are, things like ATM buttons actually are cell phones, are just petri dishes of pathogens and germs, and most of us do not clean our cell phones very often. And yet we have this idea because of the associations that we know very specifically between toilets and waste from the human body, that toilets are really, really filthy. And yet we don't give a second thought to things like keyboards or cell phones and other sorts of things that people are touching
一个观点阐述得更透彻一些，我认为这真的很有趣。那就是：美好并不能压倒邪恶。就像邪恶可以压倒美好那样。因此，事实上，在其他实验中，他发现这样一种观点，例如：你如何去净化像希特勒穿过的毛衣这样的东西？所以人们被告知希特勒拥有这件毛衣，你是否愿意在不同的条件下穿它？
all the time and could be very dirty and contagious. I wanna talk about a certain quality that disgusting things have, Rachel, which is that they tend to almost infect the things around them. As the psychologist Paul Rosen, who's done a lot of work on disgust says, a single cockroach will destroy the appeal of a bowl of cherries, but a single cherry doesn't make a bowl of cockroaches appealing. Why do disgusting things infect the things around them? Well, first I want to make a sort of fleshed out
或者你是否愿意，它在什么情况下才能变得可以接受？没有任何形式的清洗能让它变得可以接受。特蕾莎修女穿过它，可能会让它稍微可以接受一点。但在希特勒毛衣的情况下，为了让它变得可以接受，它必须被彻底销毁并烧掉。所以美好并不能净化邪恶。但在希特勒毛衣的情况下，为了让它变得可以接受，它必须被彻底销毁并烧掉。所以美好并不能净化邪恶，正如邪恶
a point there that I think is really interesting. And that is that good does not overpower evil. The way evil can overpower good. And so in fact, in other experiments, he found that the idea, for instance, of how could you purify something like Hitler's sweater. So people are told that Hitler owned the sweater and would you be willing to wear it under varying conditions?
可以玷污美好那样。然而，哪怕只是一点点不好的东西，比如一杯水或牛奶或其他任何东西里面的一只蟑螂，都有能力摧毁整个东西。因为从我们的天性结构来看，负面性要普遍得多，也强大得多。
Or would you be, how when could it become okay? And no form of cleaning could make it okay. Mother Teresa, wearing it, could make it a little bit okay. But in the case of Hitler's sweater, it had to be totally destroyed and burned in order for it to be okay. So good does not sanct. But in the case of Hitler's sweater, it had to be totally destroyed and burned in order for it to be okay. So good does not sanctify bad in the way that bad
事实上，这具有适应性，因为与其对可能是善意的事物过度兴奋，不如担心那些可能伤害我们的事物来得更好。我记得多年前做过一篇报道，雷切尔，它探讨了一个略微相关的观点。这是社会学家安·鲍尔斯（Ann Bowers）的研究，她当时在研究二手结婚戒指的市场。她发现，当人们得知曾经拥有那枚婚戒的夫妇已经离婚时，他们非常不愿意买这枚婚戒。而人们往往更倾向于购买这样的婚戒：那段婚姻背后曾有过某种悲壮的爱情故事，但夫妻俩曾非常幸福地在一起。所以我不确定这是否完全是同一个概念，但它确实让人感觉无生命的东西
can sanctify good. Whereas just one spot of something bad, like a cockroach, for instance, in a glass of water or milk or anything else, has the capacity to destroy the whole thing. Because negativity is much more pervasive and powerful from the way that we are built.
有时会随身携带（如果你愿意这么说的话）一种精神——这是一个不科学的想法——一种有生命之物的精神。嗯，实际上这完全是同一个概念，尚卡尔，你所谈论的是一种叫做“顺势巫术”的东西，它绝对在厌恶感以及我们通过联想而感到厌恶的事物中发挥着作用。“一旦接触，终身接触”的观念。
And this is in fact adaptive because it's better to be worried about things that can harm us than overly excited about things such as might be benevolent. I remember doing a story some years ago Rachel that looked at a slightly related idea. This was worked by the sociologist Anne Bowers and she was studying the market for used wedding rings. And she found that people were really reluctant to buy a wedding ring when they learned that the couple who had previously owned that wedding ring had gotten divorced. And people tended to want wedding rings where, you know, there had been some tragic love story, but the couple had been very happy together. So I'm not sure if it's exactly the same concept, but it really feels as if inanimate objects
例如，那枚曾戴在一个婚姻糟糕并最终离婚的女人手指上的戒指，不知何故，尽管这枚戒指现在躺在一家珠宝店里，与最初的那对夫妇毫无关系。那段糟糕婚姻的本质不知何故仍然留在那枚戒指里。因此，戴上这枚戒指就会把那段糟糕的婚姻“赋予”给新的佩戴者。不知何故，正如你所说，这种精神会超越物质并感染新的婚姻。
can sometimes carry with them the spirit, if you will, it's an unscientific idea, the spirit of living things. Well, actually it is very much the same concept, Shankar, and what you're talking about is something called sympathetic magic, which definitely plays a role in discussed and what we're disgusted by through association. The idea of once in contact, always in contact.
有时确实会带有某种精神，如果你愿意这么说的话，这是一种不科学的想法，即生命体的精神。实际上，这其实是同一个概念，尚卡尔，你所谈论的是一种叫做顺势巫术的东西，它绝对在厌恶以及我们通过联想产生的厌恶感中发挥着作用。这就是“一旦接触，永远联系”的观念。
So for example, the ring that was on the finger of the woman who had a terrible marriage and ended up getting divorced, somehow even though that ring is now in a jewelry shop, has nothing to do with that original couple whatsoever. The essence of that bad marriage is somehow still in the ring. And therefore, wearing that ring will therefore impart the bad marriage onto the new wearer. And somehow this spirit, as you said, will transcend and infect the new marriage.
所以举个例子，那枚戒指曾戴在一个婚姻糟糕并最终离婚的女性手上，不知为何，尽管这枚戒指现在在一家珠宝店里，与那个原本的伴侣完全没有任何关系。那段糟糕婚姻的本质不知为何依然留在这枚戒指里。因此，戴上这枚戒指就会把这段糟糕的婚姻转嫁给新的佩戴者。不知为何，正如你所说，这种精神会超越并感染新的婚姻。
So it's again, it's a form of infection. You have a very simple and interesting thought experiment in your book, which is, I'm not disgusted at the thought that when I drink a glass of water, that there is saliva in my mouth. But if I spit in a glass of water, and then I drink that glass of water, that seems disgusting. And of course, in both cases, it's exactly the same outcome.
所以这也是一种感染。你在书里提到了一个非常简单且有趣的思想实验：我不觉得当我喝一杯水时，嘴里的唾液有什么恶心的。但如果我往水杯里吐口水，然后把那杯水喝下去，那就显得很恶心了。当然，在这两种情况下，结果完全是一样的。
I have water in my mouth with saliva in my mouth. Why does it feel more disgusting in one case and not the other? So that's exactly a great point about the idea that discussed is about the outside coming in and contaminating our inside. So while the saliva and the water is in our mouth, it's inside of us, and even just take water out of the equation, just the fact that you have saliva in your mouth right now, we're all okay with that. But as soon as we spit that exact same saliva
我嘴里有水，水里混着唾液。为什么在一种情况下会觉得恶心，而在另一种情况下不会呢？所以这就很好地说明了一个观点：恶心感来自于外部事物进入并污染了我们的内部。因此，当唾液和水还在我们口中时，它是我们身体内部的一部分；甚至不用把水算进去，仅仅是你现在嘴里就有唾液这件事，我们大家都可以接受。但只要我们把嘴里一模一样的唾液
that's in our mouth into the glass, and then look at that, and then I'm telling you, now you should drink that, it all of a sudden, even though it's only been out in the air for seconds, has become contaminated by the outside and bringing it back into our body is now an entirely different proposition.
吐到杯子里，然后看着它，接着我告诉你，现在你应该把它喝下去，突然之间——尽管它暴露在空气中只有几秒钟——它就被外部环境污染了，而把它重新带回我们的体内，现在就成了一件完全不同的事。
And the fact also, I think in this case, that even though I know it's my saliva, it could be your saliva, it could be anybody else's saliva. Suddenly it becomes equalized with all this saliva that I know is out there, that I definitely do not want in my mouth. So if someone, for instance, is talking at you and spitting while they're talking enthusiastically, we're disgusted by the fact that some spit could touch us. Just like once our spit is outside of our mouth, it becomes much less pleasant to think about taking it back in. There was a really interesting study done about sharing your toothbrush. And this
而且我认为，在这种情况下，即使我知道那是我的唾液，它也可以是你的唾液，或是任何其他人的唾液。突然之间，它就和所有那些我知道存在于外界、我绝对不想弄进嘴里的唾液混为一谈了。所以，举个例子，如果有人一边对你说话，一边热情洋溢地喷着口水，我们就会对可能接触到某些口水感到恶心。就像一旦我们的口水离开了口腔，再想把它吞回去就会让人觉得很不愉快。曾有一项非常有趣的研究，关于共用牙刷。而这项
study found that, so again the idea that you know you're having to have something in your mouth that somebody else had in their mouth. And it was found that the person that one would least like to share your tooth brush with is the boss that you don't like. Followed by, so if you don't like your boss, you definitely do not want to share your tooth brush with him or her. However, the anchor person on your local news station, if they were attractive, was pretty fine to share a toothbrush with. And people in your direct family or your best friends were also okay to share a toothbrush with. And so this speaks to two things. One, familiarity and emotional connection. So people in your family or your best friends, you feel positively towards them, you're very familiar with them,
研究发现——同样是那种你得让别人放进嘴里的东西也放进自己嘴里的概念——人们最不愿意共用牙刷的对象，是你讨厌的老板。其次是，如果你讨厌你的老板，你绝对不想和他或她共用牙刷。然而，如果你当地新闻节目的当红主播长得很吸引人，和他们共用牙刷其实还挺可以接受的。而你的直系亲属或最好的朋友，也是可以共用牙刷的对象。这就说明了两点。第一，熟悉感和情感联系。所以对于家人或挚友，你会对他们抱有好感，对他们非常熟悉，
and therefore you sort of feel safe around their saliva. The good looking person on the television, beauty equals health equals okay. But the person that you dislike or the person who's a stranger is a lot likely to be either more contaminating or because you don't like them purely because you don't like them. They could be good looking and you could know they're very healthy but if you don't like them purely because you don't like them. They could be good looking and you could know they're very healthy, but if you don't like them, then you don't want anything about them coming into you as in their toothbrush. Contacts is key when it comes to disgust. In October 1972, a plane crashed in an isolated region of the Andes mountain
因此你对他们的唾液会有一种安全感。电视上的帅哥美女，美貌等于健康等于没问题。但你讨厌的人或陌生人，更有可能带来污染，或者纯粹因为你讨厌他们。他们可能长得很帅，你也知道他们非常健康，但如果纯粹因为你讨厌他们，那你就不希望他们身上的任何东西进入你体内，比如共用牙刷。在谈到恶心感时，情境是关键。1972年10月，一架飞机在安第斯山脉的偏远地区
range. There were 45 people on board, most of them rugby players traveling to Chile for a competition. Many passengers died upon impact, more died in the coming days because of the freezing cold and dwindling food supply. In the end, 16 people had to survive more than two months in the mountains, and their story has inspired movies, books, and documentaries like this one from the History Channel. I said Nando, there isn't anything left in the storage compartments where we kept the chocolates and the can of sardines that we had. And Nando looked me in the eye and said, garlitos, I want to eat the pilot. The people that had this idea and wanted to convince
坠毁。机上共有45人，其中大部分是前往智利参加比赛的橄榄球运动员。许多乘客在撞击时丧生，由于严寒和日渐减少的食物供应，更多人在随后的几天里死去。最终，有16人在山里坚持了两个多月才得以幸存，他们的故事启发了许多电影、书籍和纪录片，比如历史频道的这部。我对南多说，我们存放巧克力和沙丁鱼罐头的储藏室里什么都不剩了。南多看着我的眼睛说，加利托斯，我想吃飞行员。那些萌生了这个想法，并试图说服
the other members that this was the only way they were going to survive did two things. One, they told the people to think of this as what you're doing is eating just meat. So don't think about this as a person, kind of connected to, we don't think about eating cows and pigs, so much as we think of eating pork and beef. So this is just meat.
其他成员这是他们唯一的生存之道的那些人，做了两件事。第一，他们告诉大家把这当作仅仅是在吃肉。所以不要把这看作是一个人，这就好比我们吃牛猪肉时，不会把它们当成活生生的动物，而是把它们当成猪肉和牛肉来想。所以这只是肉。
And the second thing is that they try to justify this in another kind of a moral way by saying that the death of their compatriots was, would have been sort of a complete waste if it couldn't be used in this way that potentially aid in their survival. And so, reluctantly at first, but then everybody joined in, ate the dead remains of the people that were around them, and another thing they did. We made a pact, and we did what people do now. People give blood to friends, to family members.
第二件事是，他们试图用另一种道德方式来为之辩解，他们说，如果同伴们的死不能以这种方式得到利用，从而潜在地帮助他们生存下来，那么这种牺牲将会是一种彻底的浪费。于是，起初虽然很不情愿，但后来大家都加入了进来，吃掉了身边死者的遗体，他们还做了另一件事。我们立下了契约，我们做了现在人们也会做的事。人们会把血捐给朋友、家人。
They make organ transplants, you know? And we made a pact. We said, okay, hand in hand. If I die, please use my body. So at least one of us can get out of here. So the fact that this is about cannibalism and that the people willingly resorted to this is something which has really caught our imagination because willingly resorted to this is something which is really caught our imagination because it really leads to this question of what
你知道的，人们会进行器官移植。而我们立下了契约。我们说，好，手拉手。如果我死了，请用我的身体。这样至少我们当中能有人活着离开这里。因此，这件事涉及同类相食，而且人们是自愿诉诸这一点的，这确实深深抓住了我们的想象力，因为人们自愿诉诸于此，确实引发了这样一个问题：
would you do in that circumstance? Would you also, you know, traverse the line into this worst taboo? One of the things that I find interesting is that when I personally think about their behavior, I don't necessarily feel disgusted by what they did. In the same way that if you told me that someone was munching on their neighbor's arm, there's something about essentially having your hand forced by circumstances, you're acting in a way that is the only way you can possibly survive, that changes the way I think about whether this is disgusting. Exactly. It's only really disgusting when it's a willful, unnecessary behavior. So like you said, you kill your neighbor and then decide to eat them.
在这种情况下你会怎么做？你也会，你知道的，越过底线做出这种最糟糕的禁忌吗？我发现有趣的事情之一是，当我个人思考他们的行为时，我并不一定会对他们所做的事情感到厌恶。就像如果你告诉我有人在啃他们邻居的手臂，由于环境所迫而不得不这么做，你的行为是你为了生存而唯一能做出的方式，这改变了我对这种行为是否令人厌恶的看法。没错。只有当这是一种故意的、不必要的行为时，它才真正令人厌恶。就像你说的，你杀了你的邻居，然后决定吃掉他们。
But someone who is forced into this situation and the only way that they can survive is by resorting to an opportunistic situation that the person is already dead. That's a lot different. But the act itself, eating someone who's dead, eating another dead human being, is the same. And again, this is how our mind changes the behavior from being okay to something completely abhorrent. Rachel, you describe a case that took place in the 1990s.
但如果是一个被迫陷入这种境地，而唯一能生存下去的方式就是利用一个已经死亡的人留下的机会的人。那就很不一样了。但这种行为本身，吃掉一个死人，吃另一个已经死去的同类，是一样的。再说一次，这就是我们的心灵如何将行为从可以接受变成完全令人厌恶的东西。雷切尔，你描述了一个发生在上世纪90年代的案件。
A man was stomp to death after propositioning another man, and when the case was taken to court, the defendant successfully used something known as the gay panic defense. You say this idea is rooted in a misconception about disgust? So this idea that in this sense, using the gay panic defense. So in this case, someone was able to convince the jury that the idea of this man making a homosexual advance to him was so repugnant that being motivated to kill this person was somehow justified. And like you said, it actually was successful in the trial. Now, the concept that I think, so this is sort of, this is moralizing and this is getting
一名男子在向另一名男子表白后被群殴致死，当案件闹上法庭时，被告成功使用了被称为“同性恋恐慌”的辩护理由。你说这个想法根源于对厌恶的误解？所以在这种情况下，利用同性恋恐慌辩护。因此，在这种情况下，有人能够说服陪审团，这个男人向他进行同性恋示好的想法是如此令人反感，以至于产生杀害这个人的动机在某种程度上是合理的。正如你所说，它在审判中确实成功了。现在，我认为这个概念，所以这是某种程度上，这是道德化，这正在
people to become less judgmental towards the act of murder because of the fact that they felt a kind of a sympathy towards the feeling of a version that this person must have had and therefore this sort of outburst of rage is somehow justified. The thing that's different about this, and I think this is an interesting point about disgust in what makes it different from anger, which I think it's often confused with, is that disgust is about recoiling from, moving away from, avoiding the stimulus that's making you disgust it. And if someone were truly disgusted by somebody else, they would not want to get all over them and beat
让人们对谋杀行为减少批判，因为他们对这个人必然感受到的厌恶情绪产生了一种同情，因此这种愤怒的爆发在某种程度上是合理的。这其中不同的一点，我认为这是关于厌恶的一个有趣点，它与愤怒有何不同（人们经常将它们混淆），那就是厌恶是关于退缩、远离、避开让你感到厌恶的刺激物。如果一个人真的对另一个人感到厌恶，他们不会想扑到对方身上去殴打
them to get death and get their blood and everything else all over them, because that would be even more disgusting if you're already disgusted. Instead, if I'm really angry, if I'm enraged by something, then I attack, then I approach, then I can demolish you and get all covered in you and it doesn't matter because I'm just in a rage. So really, the idea about this being discussed is wrong, and what it was, is this person was affronted, somehow morally, personally, whatever the case might be, and incited into such a rage that then he wanted to murder this person. So the idea of using disgust in this way is actually flawed because the person is not
他们致死，把他们的血和其他东西弄得满身都是，因为如果你已经感到厌恶了，那会更加令人作呕。相反，如果我真的很愤怒，如果我对某事暴怒，那么我会攻击，我会靠近，然后我会摧毁你，浑身沾满你的体液也无所谓，因为我正在盛怒之中。所以，认为这是厌恶的想法是错误的，实际情况是，这个人受到了某种道德上、个人上或其他方面的冒犯，被激怒到了极点，从而想要谋杀这个人。因此，以这种方式使用厌恶的想法实际上是有缺陷的，因为这个人不是
disgusted, they're just enraged. So that example of homophobia, Rachel ritual makes me think about an idea. In almost every society you go to, you see patterns of disgust that are modeled on social hierarchies. In many countries, you have the rich who are disgusted by the poor or upper caste who are disgusted by lower caste or people who are native citizens being disgusted by foreigners. What do you think explains this? It has to do with something more insidious
厌恶，他们只是暴怒。所以同性恋恐惧症的那个例子，雷切尔·里丘尔让我想到了一个观点。在几乎你去的每一个社会里，你都会看到以社会等级为模特的厌恶模式。在许多国家，富人对穷人感到厌恶，或者高种姓对低种姓感到厌恶，或者本地公民对外国人感到厌恶。你认为这说明了什么？这与更具隐蔽性的东西有关
and that's related to our feelings about our social environment and the people that are in it. And the idea that foreigners and strangers and so forth are threats to our social normal order and that that then becomes somehow connected to our ideas about contamination and protecting us somehow. And the idea is that this somehow justifies and rationalizes racial prejudices and other kinds of prejudices, because if we stay away from the unfamiliar and the foreign, because
这与我们对社会环境以及身处其中的人们的感受有关。这种观点认为，外国人、陌生人等等对我们的社会正常秩序构成了威胁，然后这在某种程度上与我们关于污染和保护我们的想法联系在一起。这种观点认为，这在某种程度上为种族偏见和其他种族偏见进行了辩解和合理化，因为如果我们远离不熟悉的事物和外国人，因为
we don't know what those immigrants, you know, they could be diseased, and in fact, disease was often used as a way of anti-immigrant propaganda. This somehow justifies negative attitude towards them when there is no relationship between their ability to actually make a sick or not. In much of our life, disgust feels instinctive. When we see a cockroach and a kitchen counter counter or smell rotten food in the trash can, our revulsion feels hardwired. But Rachel says it's not. Our sense of disgust is learned. The things that disgust us not only reveal a lot about our culture,
我们不知道那些移民，你知道的，他们可能会携带疾病，事实上，疾病经常被用作反移民宣传的一种方式。当他们并没有能力真正让人生病与否时，这在某种程度上为针对他们的负面态度进行了辩解。在我们的大部分生活中，厌恶感感觉是本能的。当我们在厨房台面上看到一只蟑螂，或者闻到垃圾桶里腐烂食物的气味时，我们的反感感觉像是与生俱来的。但雷切尔说并非如此。我们的厌恶感是后天习得的。让我们感到厌恶的事物不仅揭示了我们的许多文化，
they reveal a great deal about our minds. She remembers an instructive episode from her own childhood. As we were driving in the car, and it was a beautiful sunny summer day, and the windows were rolled down, and we were going by fields, and everything was very pretty. My mother from the front seat said, oh, I love that smell. And so, as I was smelling the same thing, and all kinds of nice things were in my visual scene, and my mother who I love said, I love that smell. I thought, okay, this is a great smell. And I then learned a few years later that saying that in response to that smell was a very big mistake. So the smell turned out
它们还极大地揭示了我们的思想。她记起了自己童年的一次教育意义的经历。当时我们正坐在车里，那是一个阳光明媚的美丽夏日，车窗摇了下来，我们开过田野，一切都非常美丽。我妈妈从前座说，哦，我喜欢那个气味。所以，当我闻到同样的气味时，视野中出现了各种美好的事物，而我深爱的妈妈说，我喜欢那个气味。我想，好吧，这是一个极好的气味。然后几年后我才知道，对那种气味做出那样的回答是一个非常大的错误。所以那个气味原来是
to be skunk. So when I said, I love that smell on the playground with all bunch of little kids around me and they went, ew, disgusting, that skunk, oh you're so gross and so forth and ran away from me. Again, so I become now, this skunk, because they all ran away from me. I realized that was not the socially appropriate thing to say and so I kept that to myself for quite a while. But it turns out I'm not alone.
臭鼬。所以当我在操场上对周围的一群小孩子们说“我喜欢那个气味”时，他们说，“呃，好恶心，那是臭鼬，哦你好恶心”之类的话，然后从我身边跑开。又一次，我变成了现在这样，这个臭鼬，因为他们都从我身边跑开了。我意识到那不是社会上得体的言论，所以我把它藏在心里好一阵子。但事实证明我并不孤单。
There are actually people who like the smell of skunk and that also leads into something interesting about our sense of smell. In fact, we don't all smell skunk in the same way. So both our minds and the way our noses in fact react to the chemical that makes up skunk is different. So unless you have an identical twin, your receptors in your nose are actually only yours and nobody else shares them, even though there's a lot of overlap.
实际上有些人喜欢臭鼬的气味，这也引出了关于我们嗅觉的一些有趣的事情。事实上，我们并不是以同样的方式闻到臭鼬的气味。因此，无论是我们的思想还是我们的鼻子对构成臭鼬气味的化学物质的反应方式都是不同的。所以除非你有一个同卵双胞胎，否则你鼻子里的受体实际上只属于你，没有人与你分享，尽管有很多重叠之处。
So I buy the idea that we're all not smelling the same thing when we smell skunk that are the receptors in our noses and the way our brains work, you know, we might be smelling different things. But it's also, what I find really fascinating about the story is that there is so much about disgust that is actually learned. You heard your mother, you have an association
所以我接受这个观点，即当我们闻到臭鼬时，我们闻到的并不是同一样东西，因为我们鼻子里的受体和大脑的工作方式，你知道的，我们闻到的可能是不同的东西。但这也是，我发现这个故事真正迷人的是，有那么多关于厌恶的东西其实是后天习得的。你听到了你母亲的话，你将
between your mother and the beautiful scenery around you, and you learn in some ways whether something that's a strong smell is a positive smell or a negative smell. And in many ways, this runs counter to the way most of us think about disgust. We think of it as being this innate drive that if I find something disgusting, you're going to smell it and you're going to find a disgusting as well. So I think that brings up a great way to think about the idea of disgust and it is that it is the instinct that has to be learned. So once we learn what something disgusting is, we then feel disgusted by it like for
你的母亲与你周围美丽的风景联系在一起，你在某种程度上学会了某种强烈气味到底是积极的气味还是消极的气味。在许多方面，这与我们大多数人对厌恶的看法背道而驰。我们认为它是一种本能的驱使，如果我发现某样东西令人厌恶，你闻到它也会觉得它令人厌恶。所以我想这提出了一个思考厌恶感概念的绝佳方式，那就是它是一种必须后天学习的本能。所以一旦我们知道了某种令人厌恶的东西是什么，我们就会对它感到厌恶，比如
instance bodily products and toilet training and you know poop and so forth. We don't have a question about whether or not it's disgusting especially if it's from somebody else where also is where meaning and context come into play. But we did not think it was disgusting from the get go. So that is to say, we were not hardwired or born thinking that poop was gross. In fact, many infants both like to play with poop. They like the smell of poop. They don't have any reactions to things.
例如身体排泄物、如厕训练、便便等等。我们不会去质疑它是否令人厌恶，特别是如果它来自别人的时候，这也是意义和语境发挥作用的地方。但我们从一开始并不认为它是令人厌恶的。也就是说，我们天生并不是生来就认为便便很恶心的。事实上，许多婴儿既喜欢玩便便。他们喜欢便便的气味。他们对事物没有任何反应。
For instance, that adults in the same community think of as positive or negative. In fact, a great demonstration I like to do is showing these facial expressions of babies getting either the smell of sort of sweaty socks and vomit versus the smell of vanilla. And some babies' faces to the sweaty socks and vomit are making big smiley faces, and others to the smell of vanilla are making what we would call disgust faces. So you know, there's nothing hardwired about the reaction either to smells or to things that are disgusting.
例如，同一个社区的成年人认为是积极或消极的事情。事实上，我喜欢做的一个绝佳示范是展示婴儿闻到汗袜子和呕吐物的气味与闻到香草气味时的面部表情。有些婴儿面对汗袜子和呕吐物时做出了灿烂的笑脸，而另所以，无论是对气味的反应还是对令人厌恶的事物的反应，没有什么东西是生来就注定的。
But once we learn what the meaning is, we then stick to it except for when the context can make it very confusing or the context changes the way we perceive something. I love this idea that in many ways our notions of disgust are constructed. I understand that Americans like winter green flavor chewing gum, but people in Britain not so much. So in the UK, winter green mint is used exclusively in toilet cleaning products and in some medicinal bombs, like things you would rub on your skin if you're in pain. And so they're connected, the smell is connected to either
但是一旦我们知道了含义是什么，我们就会坚持这种看法，除非语境会让人感到非常困惑，或者语境改变了我们对某事物的感知。我非常喜欢这种观点，即在许多方面，我们的厌恶观念是被构建出来的。据我所知，美国人喜欢冬青口味的口香糖，但英国人没那么喜欢。所以在英国，冬青薄荷专门用于厕所清洁产品和一些药用软膏，比如如果你感到疼痛时涂在皮肤上的东西。所以它们是连在一起的，气味与
being in pain or cleaning the toilet. So not good. In the US, however, the scent is used in candies and in gums, it's connected to the taste of sweet and sweet actually is innately positive. So tasting sweet plus smelling something that's gonna be good. And we don't have any connection to cleaning the bathroom or being in pain when we smell this odor.
处于疼痛之中或打扫厕所联系在一起。所以这不好。然而在美国，这种香味被用于糖果和口香糖中，它与甜味联系在一起，而甜味实际上天生就是积极的。所以品尝甜味加上闻到感觉很好的东西。当我们闻到这种气味时，我们没有任何与打扫浴室或经历疼痛的联系。
And so as a function of the connections that we have learned to it and what the meaning is, this odor which in and of itself is totally, you know, agnostic, it doesn't have meaning one way or the other becomes good or becomes bad as a function of that. So the British and the Americans are divided on the subject of wintergreen. But I'm absolutely sure they'd come together when it comes to eating bugs. Eating happened. My heart's pounding oh my god. They look like crickets. There's no sugar coating. I'm about to throw up if I stay here.
因此，作为我们对它习得的联系以及其含义的函数，这种气味本身完全是，你知道的，不可知论的，它本身没有正面或负面的含义，由于这种函数，它变成了好的或坏的。因此，英国人和美国人在冬青这一主题上存在分歧。但我绝对确信，在吃昆虫这方面，他们会达成一致。吃虫子发生了。我的心在狂跳，哦天哪。它们看起来像蟋蟀。没有什么好掩饰的。如果我待在这儿，我快要吐了。
I don't want to do it. like crickets. There's no sugar coating. I'm about to throw up if I stay here. Those are reactions from a couple of our NPR co-workers when we presented them with a plate of dried crickets and asked them to take a bite. Can I get the old my water bottle? Can I have a chaser? I'm cool bugs as long as they're outside. I'm not sure how cool I am with them being in my mouth. It's disgusting. It's insects. Look at it. There's exoskeletons everywhere, pieces of legs. This is gross. People eat this. There's a couple of things which disgust us about bugs. One of them is that we don't consider them to be food.
我不想吃。像蟋蟀。没有什么好掩饰的。如果我待在这儿，我快要吐了。这些是我们的一些NPR同事在我们将一盘干蟋蟀摆在他们面前并请他们咬一口时的反应。能给我我的水瓶吗？我能要一杯饮料缓冲一下吗？只要它们在外面，我对虫子就没意见。我不确定我对把它们放进嘴里这事感觉如何。这太恶心了。这是昆虫。看看它。到处都是外骨骼，腿的碎片。这太 gross（恶心）了。人们居然吃这个。有几件事让我们对虫子感到厌恶。其中之一是，我们不认为它们是食物。
Now, there are cultures, especially in Southeast Asia, that do consider all kinds of bugs as food. And if you were to go to Thailand, you'd see Madagascar hissing cockroaches on display in the market where people are actually buying them to eat them up for meals and prepare them in all kinds of ways which apparently, although I don't know, personally, can be quite delicious. But the idea of what food is is a really interesting concept because this again speaks to how disgust is learned. And when we decide that something is edible, then it's okay to eat and other cultures
现在，有些文化，尤其是东南亚的文化，确实把各种各样的虫子当作食物。如果你去泰国，你会看到市场上陈列着马达加斯加鸣蠊，人们实际上在那里买它们来当饭吃，并以各种方式烹制它们，虽然我个人不知道，但据说这可以相当美味。但什么是食物的概念是一个非常有趣的观点，因为这再次说明了厌恶感是如何习得的。当我们决定某样东西是可食用的，那么吃它就是可以接受的，而其他文化
think differently about that. The other thing about bugs is that they move in a way that seems to be related to one of the aspects of disgust underlying why we don't like them. And this is actually somewhat connected to bodily fluids. So bugs move in a kind of a jerky or slithery or slimy kind of way. And those kinds of things actually have a similarity
对此有不同的看法。关于虫子的另一件事是，它们的运动方式似乎与我们不喜欢它们的潜在厌恶感之一有关。这实际上在某种程度上与体液有关。所以虫子的运动方式有点抽搐、滑溜或黏糊糊的。这些东西实际上具有相似性
to body products that we are also disgusted by. So being disgusted by slugs, for instance, is to do the fact that slugs are similar visually to feces. So there is this kind of continuum about our association between what bugs are and what bodily fluids are that were disgusted by. So there's a variety of reasons why bugs are disgusting. One of the things in your book that caught my eye was even in the same country in different periods of time, our attitudes about what's disgusting have changed or can change enormously. I understand that a few centuries ago, lobster was not quite seen the way that it was in Massachusetts. No, lobster was actually considered vermin of the sea and only suitable for slaves. And in fact, there was a slave uprising against the idea that it was completely cruel
与我们同样感到厌恶的身体排泄物。例如，对蛞蝓感到厌恶，与蛞蝓在视觉上类似于粪便这一事实有关。因此，在我们对虫子是什么与我们厌恶的体液之间的联想存在着某种连续性。所以虫子令人厌恶有各种各样的原因。你书中最吸引我眼球的一点是，即使在同一个国家不同的历史时期，我们对什么是恶心的态度也发生了或能够发生巨大的变化。据我所知，几个世纪前，龙不像是马萨诸塞州现在那样看待的。不，龙虾实际上被认为是海里的害虫，只适合奴隶吃。事实上，曾发生过一场奴隶起义，反对把龙虾当作食物给人们吃每周超过三次完全是残酷
and unusual punishment to give people lobster to eat more than three times a week. And today we might say, oh, how lucky to be able to afford to have lobster three times a week. So it's conceivable then, maybe in a few decades or maybe in a couple of centuries from now, we will think of eating cockroaches and crickets very differently than we do today. In fact, there are some people who would argue that insects are a very efficient source of protein, and they are plentiful, and in some ways consuming insects might actually
而不寻常的惩罚的观念。而今天我们可能会说，哦，能够每周吃得起龙虾是多么幸运啊。所以可以想象，也许在几十年后，或者从现在起几个世纪后，我们对待吃蟑螂和蟋蟀的看法将与今天截然不同。事实上，有些人会认为昆虫是非常高效的蛋白质来源，它们数量丰富，而且在某些方面食用昆虫实际上可能
be good for the environment in all kinds of different ways. I'm personally a vegetarian, so I don't know if I'll ever subscribe to eating crickets and cockroaches, but presumably our attitudes towards eating insects could change. Absolutely. So the idea also, one of the things that made lobster, disgusting, and unappealing is that it was slave food, it was prisoner food. So these people, these are bad people in the kind of the hierarchy of humans. And therefore it's okay for them to eat things that are possibly that we would consider disgusting, but not okay for me, you know,
对环境在各种不同的方面都有好处。我个人是个素食主义者，所以我不知道自己是否会去尝试吃蟋蟀和蟑螂，但据推测我们对待吃昆虫的态度可能会改变。绝对的。所以这个想法也一样，让龙虾变得恶心且没有吸引力的原因之一是它是奴隶的食物，它是囚犯的食物。所以这些人，在人类的等级制度中是坏人。因此他们吃我们可能认为令人厌恶的东西是可以接受的，但对于我来说是不行的，你知道的，
the elevated person, whatever I think of myself as being. And right now, the way we think about insects is similar to that. So people who are not like us, people who have to resort to the, you know, the last measure is possible for survival, they're gonna, you know, debase themselves to eat insects.
那个高贵的人，无论我认为自己是什么样的人。而现在，我们看待昆虫的方式也是类似的。所以那些与我们不同的人，不得不诉诸于，你知道的，为了生存而采取的最后手段的人，他们会，你知道的，贬低自己去吃昆虫。
But if we think about it entirely differently, so if we remoralize the story and and instead make eating insects about saving the planet and make it a virtuous thing to do, rather than somehow a debased thing to do or a last resort thing to do, we could in fact make it a very positive thing. While some of our co-workers shrank it first when they held the cricket in their hand, the more you look in his eyes, the less you want to eat it. The looks of fear and disgust faded after the first crunch. Cheers. Cheers.
但如果我们完全不同地看待它，如果我们重新将这个故事道德化，转而把吃昆虫看作是拯救地球并使其成为一件高尚的事情，而不是某种贬低的事情或最后手段的事情，我们实际上可以把它变成一件非常积极的事情。虽然我们的一些同事一开始在手里拿着蟋蟀时退缩了，但你越看着它的眼睛，你就越不想吃它。在第一口嘎吱声之后，恐惧和厌恶的表情消退了。干杯。干杯。
It's just like chips kind of. It's good, it's a little earthy. It's like sunflower seed or something. Yeah, it's like maybe like a basket of these like before my little pangs. Along with the whole crickets, we also provided samples of delectable protein bars made of cricket flour. I chose peanut butter and chocolate. If you didn't tell people this was a cricket, they wouldn't know.
它有点像薯片。很好吃，带有一点泥土气息。就像葵花籽什么的。是的，就像在我有点饿之前可能会来上一篮这种东西。除了整只蟋蟀，我们还提供了用蟋蟀粉制作的美味蛋白质棒样品。我选了花生酱和巧克力的。如果你不告诉别人这是蟋蟀做的，他们根本不会知道。
Good. It's not like there's big chunks of cricket in it, so I like it. Not bad at all. I'm trying to to be so like... American, you know, because everyone else eats crickets. It is a luxury to be able to be disgusted. From the very basic level that if you don't have anything else to eat, other than someone who's dead beside you or the cockroach on the floor, then you just do not get disgusted by that because you have to do it in order to survive.
很好。里面又没有大块的蟋蟀，所以我很喜欢。一点也不坏。我正试图，没那么……美国化，你知道的，因为其他人都在吃蟋蟀。能够感到厌恶是一种奢侈。从最基础的层面上讲，如果你除了身边死去的某个人或地板上的蟑螂之外没有什么可吃的，那么你绝对不会对这些感到厌恶，因为为了生存你必须这样做。
So it's a privilege to be able to say, no, I'd rather not have that dead person or that cockroach. I'd rather have that hamburger or the steak or that beautifully prepared dish of Portobello mushrooms. So the ability to say that we are disgusted by something actually comes from the privilege and the luxury of having abundance and having enough to sustain us that we can make the decision that we don't want this and we'd rather have that. Rachel hers is the author of That's Disgusting and the cent of desire. She also had a book out at the end of 2017. Why you eat what you eat?
所以，能够说“不，我宁愿不要那个死人或那只蟑螂，我宁愿要那个汉堡、牛排或那道精心烹制的大端口蘑菇”是一种特权。因此，我们对某事感到厌恶的能力，实际上来自于拥有丰盛食物以及足以维持我们生存的特权和奢侈，从而让我们能够做出决定：我们不想要这个，我们更想要那个。雷切尔·赫茨是《真恶心》和《欲望的气味》的作者。她还在2017年底出版了一本书：《你为什么吃你所吃的东西》？
Rachel hers, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure, Slankhark. Thank you for having me. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu and Parth Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Laura Quarell and Camilla Vargas Restrepo. Renek Cohen, Laura Quarell and Camilla Vargas-Restrepo. Special thanks to Monique Laborde. Anya Grunman is NPR's Vice President for Programming. For more hidden brain, you can follow the show on Facebook and Twitter. Please be sure to subscribe to our podcast.
雷切尔·赫茨，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常荣幸，Shankar。谢谢你的邀请。本期节目由托马斯·刘和帕思·沙尔制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡米拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。雷内克·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡米拉·巴尔加斯-雷斯特雷波。特别感谢莫尼克·拉博德。安妮·格鲁曼是NPR负责节目的副总裁。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注本节目。请务必订阅我们的播客。
I'm Shankar Vedantum. Thanks for listening. I'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维达当特。谢谢收听，我们下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。